dans un monde de pc qui n'innove plus
beaucoup asus envoie du bois
je vous présente aujourd'hui un des
derniers en dînatoire qui était sorti
par avis probablement un des pc les plus
innovants vous allez voir il se peut qu
asus et créer un ordinateur
[Musique]
je vais attaquer des vidéos par il se
peut que azou s'est créé l'ordinateur du
futur alors bon généralement c'est à que
l'asus il peut aussi y avoir d'autres
marques je cite mais là c'est vrai que
asus envoyer du bois je sais pas si vous
avez déjà vu du contenu sio le zenbook
pro duo modèle que je trouve
exceptionnellement intéressant vraiment
très intéressant parce que en fait le
monde des pc c'est un monde dans lequel
est bien pendant longtemps on a cru
qu'on avait fait le tour de tous qui
avait plus d'innovation qui avait plus
grand chose à faire c'est un petit peu
ennuyant ou a effectivement dès votre pc
vous avez votre qu'allez vous avoue
trackpad
on va essayer d'innover il ya des touch
bas ou des chapelles et on s'est dit
voilà on a fait un peu le tour la
question mais c'était sans compter sur
asus qui innove qui vont pas vraiment
très intéressant avec ce modèle
après je pense que ce qui va faire
l'internet ce modèle mais vous allez
voir quand je vais vous le détailler
c'est que chacun va se l'approprier et
va en faire ce qui veut dire en terme de
design on retrouve un peu l'esprit c'est
de de la gamme zen tout est autour de du
logo d'asus comme des petites vagues
comme un petit texte central qui
partirait de plus en plus grands c'est
assez sympa vous allez voir ce truc
franchement c'est vraiment très très
surprenant et l'upc goethe est bien
évidemment mais il sera aussi en tête
bientôt sur la chaîne d'arnaud arnaud
c'est que les cerneaux sous desarnauts
je crois qu'en ce moment en tout cas
quelques personnes qui sont sur la
chaîne ardo il ya une chaîne de teck
était plutôt orientée pc du coût plutôt
pc la google bing mais elle où j'aime
bien tester un petit peu tout ce qui
touche au gaming moyens casque ça va
venir
en tout cas déjà j'étais c'est un petit
peu quelques téléphones j'ai testé des
pc beaucoup ouais voilà c'est vraiment
mon truc
du coup justement arnaud il a récupéré
le asus dell book pro duo le nom est un
petit peu long il va le tester donc vous
aurez également son point de vue d'ici
quelques jours moi je sens mon test
avant lui dans son test après par contre
je vous invite tout de suite allé sur sa
chaîne vous avez le lien en bas d'un
description vous cliquez dessus vous
allez vous vous abonnez vous activer
les faits l'histoire merci plusieurs
puces regardez moi cette jolie bête
ajuste alors déjà quand vous regardez
comme ça on se rend compte c'est épais
c'est très effet c'est très très très
très épais mais vous allez comprendre
tout de suite pourquoi ces traits épais
regarder on n'ouvre pas qu il se
redresse c'est en fait ça qui est assez
intéressant qui est assez rigolo c'est
que ça vient vous le redresser là il est
à plat il est posé hop salève
voilà comme s'ils ont un peu de sport
dans une salle de sport aller en pousse
sur les fessiers on y va mais le
résultat est bel et bien intéressant par
contre c'est vrai que voilà je voulais
tout de suite c'est un petit peu épais
on n'est pas sur la machine la plus fine
du monde mais par contre on a un truc
qui est vraiment intéressant en terme de
proposition de valeur va d'abord sa
femme sur des connectiques ne puisse
commander la honda de l'usb 3 points 1
on a une prise jack pour 1.5 c'est pas
mal on décide du thunderbolt 3 usb type
c ici il ya de l'air qui sort on a en
tout quatre haut parleurs harman kardon
y en a un qui est planqué là vous avez
son grand frère qui et où son petit
frère comme vous voulez qu'elle l'autre
côté on à de l'usb 3 points hdmi pis si
c'est le port d'alimentation à l'arrière
vous n'avez absolument rien il n'y a pas
de porc et à l'avant non plus vous
n'avez absolument rien et si vous voulez
vraiment voir la magie et bien c'est
quand on les ouvre tout simplement
regardez moi ça c'est là que ça devient
intéressant vous avez un ordinateur avec
pas seulement un écran ici vous avez un
deuxième écran ici qu'en quatre cas du
hd oled 3840 par 2160 pixels qui
occupent 89% de la face avant avec des
bords très très faim écran 16/9 anglais
disant qu'ils sont franchement cool si
ce n'est quand vous avez les reflets ici
178 degrés d'angle de vision vous avez
franchement de quoi faire dci p3 en
dessous vous avez un deuxième écran ça
c'est le scream pas de plus d'un écran
ipes 3840 par 1100 pixels
vous n'êtes pas mal de fonctionnalités
qui permet de switcher de cet écran là à
cet écran là c'est tout vous montrer
et puis vous êtes pavé tactile pouvait
venir désactiver vous laissez votre
douala vous venez l'eau réactive et hop
vous laissez votre doigt là et ici vous
avez votre clavier qui est planqué oui
ça vous fait à l'espèce de combo clavier
pavé tactile pavé numérique écran du bas
écran du haut et là vous avez le combo
gagnant l'écran du haut qui votre écran
principal c'est là où on a la meilleure
qualité c'est l'évolution du oled c'est
là où c'est plus sympa et l'écran du bas
va quand même
vous servir vous allez voir il ya pas
mal de cas d'usagé bien évidemment votre
écran en est complètement tactile
pourrait venir l'utiliser utiliser
windows bonsoir c'est un grand classique
ça marche vous connaissez l'écran du bas
est bien évidemment tactile vous avez
plusieurs possibilités tout temps aussi
pour y régler votre luminosité vous avez
des petits accès rapide pourrait venir
faire des calculs
vous pouvez venir écrire directement
votre main je sais j'étais pas très bien
vous avez excellent vegas pro spotify
enfin ce que vous voulez vos petits
raccourcis en dessous vous avez des
configurations qui sont déjà
pré-enregistrées et là ça devient
intéressant configuration numéro une
seule âme ouvrir mes applications qui
sont enregistrés dans l'ordre dans
lequel j'étais programmé vegas pro ici
google en bas et ici mon explorateur de
fichiers ça c'est peut-être que cette
enregistrés mais vous pouvez faire
exactement comme vous voulez vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'avoir ça dans cet ordre là
si par exemple je vais regarder ici ce
que j'enregistrais en numéro 2 je clique
sur le numéro deux et là ça va changer
c'est à mourrir l'ordre numéro de tel
que je vais enregistrer
c'est à dire mes photos mes paramètres
spotify mon exploit dans ce fichier est
ici l'excellent ensuite je vais cliquez
ici et là ça va maintenant avertir c'est
à dire que ce qui en bas ça pas son os
qui est en haut ça passe en bas voyez et
je peux le faire à chaque fois comme ça
je peux changer si j'ai envie de par
exemple de me regarder une vidéo en bas
je peux le faire si j'ai envie d'avoir
mon tableur excel en rouge peut le faire
voyant suspensif a tout de suite je m'en
fiche ça je veux venir le fermer j'ai
tout qui est ouvert de tous les côtés ça
tout de suite
hop ça ne m'intéresse pas je le ferme je
ferme je veux mon tableur excel en grand
ici ça par exemple les photos je m'en
fiche je mets paramètres ici je fais ce
que je veux je peux venir déplacer le
maître comme je veux comme ça je peux
vraiment bosser dans la manière dont je
le souhaite avec ici par exemple toute
ma partie du tableur ici mes paramètres
pourquoi pas mettre une vidéo par donc
là je sont très travaillés sont mes
comptes
les pilonnages venus dire aymara d un
petit film en même temps on voit un
petit clip have je me mets ça où l'arj21
spotify en bas pour choisir la musique
je fais exactement comme je veux na li
comme je veux entre les deux écrans ça
c'est vachement pratique mais c'est que
la partie émergée de l'iceberg
vous pouvez bien évidemment organiser
vos fenêtres comme vous le souhaitez
entre le haut et le bas et vous pouvez
faire bien plus de choses par exemple
vous venez cliquez ici vous cliquez là
et vous voyez tout ce qui est ouvert
directement dans votre ordinateur
explorateur de fichiers nouvel onglet
paramètres juste en dessous allait
pouvoir tenir un verrouiller
déverrouiller des claviers et là vous
avez tous vos paramètres des paramètres
de votre compte pas de plus pourrait
bien le paramétrer comme vous voulez il
ya pas mal de possibilités ça c'est
intéressant
imaginez par exemple j'ai monté
leur excellent je suis en train de
travailler chez en train de bosser pour
la maison pense que je veux mais par
contre j'ai besoin de plus de place pour
avoir accès à tout le monde alors il
parle beaucoup plus que ce que je
pourrais avoir avec mon seul écran 16/9
et ben là c'est possible grâce au
deuxième écran j'ai donc mon contenu qui
affiché directement ici et je vais le
retrouver également en bas c'était que
je peux venir scrollé entre les deux je
vais avoir mon contenu de tous les côtés
on peut le faire de cette manière là
mais je vais faire exactement de la même
manière avec différentes applications et
la jument qu'il fonctionnalités de base
mais imaginez par exemple que n'importe
quel éditeur je sais pas moi d'obus ou
ce que vous voulez puisse adapter
complètement ses programmes pour sa part
exemple pour faire un montage sur
première ou sur photoshop sur ce que
vous voulez son ter les trains de venir
organiser votre travail de façon très
simple productive intuitive et ça c'est
vachement intéressant là par exemple
peut me faire un p'tit scroll sur la
page youtube de monsieur re n'y voit
plein de choses intéressantes mais ça
valait vraiment de d'ouvrir les horizons
normalement j'ai ça ce qui est déjà
plutôt pas mal l'écran est quand même
bien de bonne qualité et là je me
retrouve avec la partie du bas je peux
vraiment anticiper ce qui va s'afficher
ici c'est plutôt bien fait ça
s'intéressent à leurs âpres
effectivement qu'on n'est pas sur les
mêmes dalles oled ps on a une différence
ils sont les plus sur le jaune on va pas
avoir la même qualité d'écran mais je
trouve que néanmoins c'est relativement
intéressant fait vraiment ce que vous
voulez le tactile marche dans un sens ou
un autre plutôt bien c'est vraiment cool
on a quatre haut parleurs certifiés
harman kardon le sont assez bien la
spatialisation est ok je trouve qu'en
tout cas en terme d'expérience lorsque
vous voulez écouter de la musique
regarder un film ça marche parfaitement
bien et en plus que vous avez une prise
jack ou à venir pousser l'expérience
beaucoup plus loin et même recherché
cros casque au terme de performances on
pardonne intel core i7 à enough
on a soit 8 soit 16 soit 32 gigas de ram
ddr 4 et vous avez soit 256 512 ou un
terrain de stockage en ssd et point de
vue carte graphique et une nvidia rtx 20
on a un clavier rétro éclairé que je
trouve assez bien au retour de touche
correct une course qui est assez courte
et qui est franchement pas mal quand je
m'étais posé la question du clavier je
me suis dit comment dans une machine
comme ça où on réussit à faire rentrer
de clé dans cette petite partie là est
ce qu'on va avoir la même taille de
clavier qui paraît dans un macbook pro
macbook pro 15 pouces et au final ça
c'est intéressant parce que regarder ce
sorti mon maître je mesure je prends ici
du contrôle jusqu'au bout ga les
vingt-sept ennemis et si je reporte ici
eh bien j'ai exactement la même chose
que j'ai exactement la même zone du
clavier sur un macbook pro que ici sur
mon ennemi
pro duo ça peut effectivement paraître
un peu plus compact ici par rapport à
mon macbook pro tout simplement parce
que c'est beaucoup plus chargé vous avez
ici le clavier le nîmes pad l'écran
l'écran ça fait beaucoup dans un petit
espace
ici par contre vous avez votre clavier
voltz barre mais c'est quand même très
drôle parce que la tête du barça comme l
innovation pourrait l'utiliser il ya pas
mal de fonctionnalités
au final 7 touch barre elle est
complètement ringardisé par ce grand
écran là et je crois au final que là où
apple a voulu innover et bien quand on
voit aujourd'hui capable de faire asus
par rapport à l'utilisation d'un second
écran dans cet espace là bas ça ridicule
un petit peu l'histoire parce que si
vous les mettez vraiment côte à côte il
vous prenait un petit peu les auteurs
vous voyez qu'en fait en termes de
taille prise en termes de death pastry
et bien c'est quasiment la même chose
j'ai beaucoup d'espèces vite j'ai
effectivement un très grand trackpad qui
est vraiment hyper hyper confortable là
c'est beaucoup plus petit c'est moins
confort néanmoins tout est tactile donc
s'il peut y avoir un vrai sens là c'est
hyper hyper chargé
là c'est très épuré le macbook pro est
quand même beaucoup moins épais là c'est
tout de suite beaucoup plus épais de
vote et y'a juste mais par contre en
terme d'optimisation par rapport aux
usages là c'est vachement top d'ailleurs
dit moi vous un commentaire si vous êtes
plus team asus ou team apple il ya
effectivement plein de points de
différences sont pas du tout les mêmes
machines mais quel est votre parti plus
marqué le mois on va en commentaire en
guise de trackpad vous avez une une
panne alors points négatifs d'une pâle
c'est qu'il est tout petit il est
minuscule pour passer d'un côté à
l'autre de l'écran il faut lever son
doigt plusieurs fois point positif c'est
que vous voyez vos chiffres d'où l'idée
que c'est pas un trackpad mais un ipad
pourrait venir avait désactivé ici si
toutefois ça vous embête vous pouvez
venir complètement naviguer dessus sans
que ça pose absolument aucun problème
asus a vraiment fait le focus sur la
productivité sur la créativité au niveau
de cette machine ce qui fait que c'est
une machine qui est destiné
effectivement aux personnes créatif et
créatif ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
mais ça peut aussi vouloir dire
graphiste d'où l'idée d'avoir l'asus
peine le petit stylet de asus petit
d'ailleurs pacifique saf et qui as
intéressant qui permet de rajouter des
usages qui fait que si vous êtes
graphiste vous allez pouvoir dire
dessiner sur l'écran du bas ça va
s'afficher sur l'écran du haut vous
allez pouvoir venir utiliser votre
stylet pour naviguer faire beaucoup de
choses avec
et ça ça marche aussi plutôt bien gardé
par exemple avec mon style je peux venir
naviguer complètement dans mon windows
ça marche c'est cool c'est pratique ça
se referme qui ont bien utilisé aussi
directement ici pour choisir ce que je
veux flipper mais application ouvrir
tous mes programmes venir dessiner je
peux venir le faire des petits
je si je veux sans aucun problème c'est
cool up afftac non toi tu ne gagneras
pas si j'insiste je veux gagner non tu
ne gagneras pas tuer ses roues et non
par personne n'a gagné en termes de
sécurité vous avez des caméras
infrarouge permet de détecter votre
village pour venir déverrouiller avec
windows et l'eau donc n'importe qui peut
pas l'évacuer photo de vous et venir
débrouiller en un clic c'est un ordi qui
en plus du wifi 6 du bluetooth 5.0 que
personnellement je trouve assez
intéressant après tout que devront
pouvoir un peu potentiellement regretter
c'est que je trouve quand même très gros
on est vraiment l ultraportable c'est
pas du tout l'adn de ce produit la ds
est plutôt un produit pour les créatifs
vous allez poser chez vous et vous allez
pouvoir l'emmener avec vous si vous
voulez pouvoir travailler tranquillement
avec ça c'est peut-être dînatoire qui
sera à mon avis destiné à rester dans un
endroit il est épais il est gros il est
un petit peu lourd on va pas le mettre
dans un sac à dos pour le glisser pour
la droite à gauche tout le temps et je
tends permanence ça peut peut-être un
peu la limite de ce produit à côté de ça
je trouve séduisant j'aime bien le
travail qui est fait entre bien le
design zen de asus dernière il avait
déjà fait fort avec leur screen page
comme ça intéressant tout cas c'était
une proposition de valeur que je
trouvais vraiment intéressante heureux
de continuer à aller dans cette idée là
la développer aller toujours plus loin
cette fois-ci vous avez les deux écrans
qu'est ce que vous allez avoir l'année
prochaine
qu'est ce que j'y vas nous faire qu'est
ce qu'ils ont volé fillon et quelle
vision de l'avenir izon pour le pc et ça
je crois en tout cas vraiment vraiment
intéressant dans cette machine allait
bien mais elle a un coût
vous vous en douterez allait pas
gratuite maj j'aimerais bien mais je l
ai pas gratuite elle un courriel un
couple est relativement il donne la
confi config par exemple vous êtes sur
intel core i7 32 gigas de ram un terrain
de stockage en ssd vous êtes à 3499
euros à 3500 euros
c'est très cher et si vous allez sur un
île 9 32 gigas de ram un terrain de
stockage 4000 euros 3999 points 99
centimes pour moi c'est 4000 euros c'est
très chiant c'est très cher mais à côté
de ça
si vous avez cette machine si vous avez
réellement besoin on va pas chez son
ordinateur
juste pour dire tiens je vais acheter un
ordinateur avec deux écrans si vous
achetez ça si vous en avez réellement
l'utilité si vous vous envoyer en tout
cas l'utilité c'est vous voyez l'utilité
de ces deux écrans de ce que vous allez
pouvoir faire avec
alors dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
banco mozart comment est-ce que vous
prendriez ses deux écrans
comment est ce que vous verrez c'est
comment est ce que vous pourriez vous
vous la preuve
parce que la question de cette machine
là c'est déjà il ya la prouesse
technique mais le truc le plus
intéressant en arrière c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir en faire et comment
pouvoir l'utiliser parce qu'avoir deux
écrans pour voir nos écrans franchement
c'est un gadget au but 15 jours vous
l'utilisez plus si par contre derrière
vous avez une réelle utilité est un réel
besoin ça peut avoir un sens si c'est
juste pour vous dire je veux même petite
vidéo youtube où je mets un petit
netflix en bossant des cours en haut je
pense pas que vous avez utilisé bien
souvent si par contre vous avez un réel
besoin
vous êtes un monteur vidéo vous voulez
utiliser par exemple une timeline pas ou
alors mettre vos roche g pouvoir faire
glisser l'organiser comme ça ou alors
sous photoshop si vous faites de la
création graphique de la trois
dimensions ça peut aussi avoir un sens
si vous êtes professionnel que vous avez
vos emails ans va votre to do list j'en
sais rien et pillon tout à parti de
productivité vous allez utiliser le plus
dans ses usages là pour moi il ya un
intérêt mais sinon clairement il ya
absolument pas d'intérêt donc à vous de
me dire comment est ce que vous vous
verriez ça comment est ce que vous
pourriez en tout cas vous adapter à vos
besoins vous soyez un particulier un
professionnel un créatif ou alors pas du
tout marc m'a tout ça en bas en
commentaire à moi personnellement je
trouve intéressante en plus que vous
avez cortana bien évidemment sur windows
mais vous avez en plus à l'est que ça
vous pouvez venir piloter votre maison
et pas mal de choses
donc c'est aussi assez intéressant je
prends le créatif on peut aussi penser
toutes les personnes qui font de
l'édition musicale c'est possèdent très
intéressant au streamer vais pouvoir
regarder des vidéos des pouvoirs on voit
le stream enfin voilà il ya plein plein
plein plein de choses pour l usage
donc à vous de vous l'approprier dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en tout
cas je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
bon boulot de la part d'asus belle
proposition de valeur c'est pas dans des
cafés pour tout le monde ça nordiques et
probablement à ces niches et pour
certains usages en tout cas ça montre
une bonne vision de l'avenir du pc et
rien que pour ça félicitations du se
trouve ça assez cool et quant à nous on
se dit à demain vous embrasse ciao